foreign
i was putting this back here
um
is
here
[Music]
all right welcome everyone to the last
session on private information retrieval
we have two talks uh the first is by
ellet who is in a super position here in
and in israel
uh elliot does uh fantastic work in
succinct cryptography and uh today she
will tell us about uh the school line of
work on uh doubly efficient pir
all right thanks abhishek and thanks for
the workshop organizers for the
invitation
um indeed i will be talking about doubly
efficient private information retrieval
this does not mean twice faster than
something else but i'll explain very
shortly what what we're doing with this
and this is a collection actually the
original works kind of the what i'll be
mostly talking about are not new they're
back around 2017 or so um so my main
goal of this talk is to sort of show you
what is out there and mostly what is not
yet known yet
and these are going to be so this will
be a big chunk of the talk things that i
want the audience to actually solve
okay but getting started so the focus
indeed is this notion of private
information retrieval
this was originally considered in a
multi-server version for today i'm only
going to be talking about the case where
there's a single server
so here there's a server that holds some
end entry database and a client who
wishes to access some item i in the
database
without revealing eye to the server so
this is the privacy
okay and as sort of expected here
there'll be some sort of potentially
interactive protocol
such that at the conclusion
the client can recover the ice entry of
the database
um the privacy is that for any
possible pair of distinct indices that
the server can't tell
which index the the client is actually
requesting and of course a
non-triviality requirement
so for example the client can just
download the entire nb database and this
gives fantastic security but we want
this to be interesting the
non-trivialities the communication must
be less than n
and interestingly enough it turns out
even as soon as you get to one bit less
than n this already inherently requires
public key cryptography
um so for those who were
into this it implies oblivious transfer
okay
on the other hand if you do have public
key cryptography assumptions so this is
a list never mind the specifics but each
of these is sort of a relatively
standard structured assumption that does
in particular imply public key
cryptography
and based on an assortment of these
things uh any one of them then you can
get single server peer with very low
communication okay so so really the
focus has been on communication up to
this point
a little bit of a minor shout out so
this is a very recent work um mine
together with collaborators
and my students
or our student rather and where we can
actually get the ddh so decisional
difficulty down to the computation of
the b helmet it's actually you know when
you look at it from from
after the solution is actually quite
simple
is it rate one or so
yeah
okay say that
again the pir that you get with all the
location is that straight one uh as was
in prior work or is it
just a cbs construction just from ghpir
with polyglot communication
um i can't hear you completely but so
this is just it doesn't go through like
this um so sorry uh yeah is it
one or just like no no just like yeah
yep
yeah just standard but in fact it has
multiple rounds of interaction and so
forth but the new thing is just the
assumption
what is the word
you know the communication uh so so each
database entry is very large right and
that's the innovation fee is large let's
say your gigabyte the communication from
the server back
[Music]
yeah the truth is we haven't really
thought about that we were just looking
at the single big case maybe it's worth
looking into
okay so that is not the focus of this
talk um but rather i want to be shifting
not just at looking at communication
which is what's mostly been looked at
here
um but shifting to the the question of
what about the computation that's
required
okay so if you look at these these
wonderful protocols typically the
computation on the client side is quite
low we're happy with this some polylog
in the database size
but unfortunately the computation on the
server side is big
okay this is inherent you cannot
in fact hope to do less than that as if
you if you just start with the database
like this
again kind of intuitively this makes
sense because for example if the server
doesn't touch one of the database items
this already gives some some indication
some bias that this was not the index
that was queried okay so this this is
something that we're a bit stuck with
okay or are we
so the
though the focus of today of this talk
and also the talk that's coming up next
is going to be looking at how can we
come up with ways of getting around this
impossibility
okay the first which is um
mostly what
alexandra will be talking about in the
next talk
suppose for example that the client can
batch a collection of queries okay and
this can either be sort of all at one
shot or maybe they come adaptively but
you require some sort of amortized
computation
okay so this this work this is exactly
what the next talk will be about um
which is really nice properties where
the the amortized computation time this
is on the server side is only square
root of the database science
okay uh the sort of the downside or the
thing that comes along with this
is that the client as part of this
process has to maintain extra storage
in their case it's it's roughly square
root as well
and in fact in some sense they show that
this is inherent
okay so
more specifically if i if this is some
server communication time t
sorry computation time t
and if s here is denoting the client
storage they prove that for adaptive
queries coming from
i'm batching together this is amortized
across queries but they're adaptive
then this product has to be at least n
so for example this this is already kind
of in some sense the best kind of
trade-off that you can get
[Music]
um they also show if you have
non-adaptive queries
and they still can show something and
this this was a actually matched already
with this previous work
um that the kind of trades up so for
example in the extreme if i have n
queries i'm trying to batch together i
can even just download the whole
database right i get really good
amortized
complexity okay so this is also not what
i'm going to be talking about sort of a
system of decoys here um instead i'm
going to be looking at a different
direction
of how to bypass this
this computation cost
so i guess this is apparent already from
your bullet but those works don't they
keep the database just as exactly the
next sentence i was about to say exactly
so so this
these works
do not touch the database so this was
back here the database is stored exactly
as is and these these lower bounds are
in that setting exactly
okay
so indeed another thing that you could
consider doing sort of relaxing
is what if we do some sort of
pre-processing on the database okay so
for example though the server can
can store some encoded version where
you've pre-processed some information
okay and this this notion was first put
forth back by bama little in 2000 by the
name of pure with pre-processing
um here just kind of for for
completeness i also want to put out that
there are some lower bounds here no
so um so if i have time t
and server extra hint storage s
okay so before this s was on the client
this is on the server side
um then we do know that s times t has to
be at least n log n
but for example if i'm okay with storing
you know say another copy of the
database size or even a bit more here
you can hope to get
the t very very small
okay
and uh and yeah so so kind of one of
some of the benefits here for example in
some sense um a benefit of this bullet
versus this bullet is that you can if i
sort of push the extra storage or
something to to the server then the
client can still be very cheap in terms
of not only kind of computation and also
storage
you'll see why there are other reasons
why this bullet is better as well so
wait for that
okay
okay so this again this is going to be
the focus and i want to sort of open
this up even a little bit further
um fortunately this got cut off here so
this should say standard one server
private information retrieval good news
is that this is here just as a baseline
this is like the version that does need
a lot of computation
i want to mention so probably
some of you in the audience have heard
of this notion of oblivious ram
this is also something whose goal is to
hide access patterns into data
it's a little bit in an orthogonal
direction
um and the reason sort of the difference
is that with oram oblivious ram the
server in every single stage is allowed
to change what's being uh held
and you're kind of local so this is tied
to a single client and the server can
keep updating what's stored on the the
server side
okay
um so sort of a distinction here with
this line is that
this pre-processing peer with
pre-processing in here is going to be
you one time
one shot pre-processed the database and
now that's that's stored as used so you
don't have to kind of maintain state on
the server side
okay so what am i putting in here well
even when i say peer with pre-processing
there's different questions
about in particular who's doing the
pre-processing okay
so the original notion which is like the
one that you'd really like
is that the server does the
pre-processing okay there's no secrets
involved the server takes the thing
encodes it
and there's nothing to hide in that
process and you can go for it
so they were able to show in this 2000
work that in the multi-server private
information retrieval setting you can
get some savings um but nothing is still
to to this day is known in the setting
for the single server case we just don't
know
okay so this this was sort of the state
of affairs when uh i got into the scene
together with uh and other co-authors
um
and uh and what so
i'll mention we kind of weren't even
really sure
is this possible maybe it is possible
maybe we can show it's impossible
um what we ended up looking at is a
slightly weaker version
okay
where there's pre-processing but
but secrets can be involved okay so
think of this as that
you know ideally some magical thing
where we run some joint protocol okay so
somehow the database gets encoded
say a trusted setup
okay and now the server holds on to this
information maybe there's some kind of
public key so this is called a public
key version
and given this now anybody can come
along and and conquer this
yeah by the way so this what is this
thing this is now finally the the
entrance of this doubly efficient peer
um
it's maybe not the best name but it is a
reasonably good name
so doubly efficient in the sense that
it's efficient for the client and also
the server so this is referring to the
low computation time
okay
um
so this this is kind of like a next best
thing maybe it's not perfect but we can
imagine settings maybe we all do some
sort of trusted set up
okay but now we're even kind of backing
off a little bit more and something that
we can get a firmer grasp on which is a
weaker version where the pre-processing
is done by the client
so now this kind of shifts over this is
like a per client
setting versus we'd like it to be that
any client comes along
and let me try to kind of justify
still this this setting one
justification is that and you can show
actually with obfuscation so kind of at
least heuristically this gives us a
construction that you can boost from
this setting to
to this setting
so the public key version right uh the
way i think about it the way i could
think about it you can correct me is i
have a database i want everybody to
access it right so i'm gonna
reprocessing
that's great actually and the other one
is
i have a database but only i want to
access it it's sort of an outsourcing
kind of so maybe maybe i should mention
though so whoever is doing this
pre-processing if they keep the secret
information then they can actually learn
what's being queried so this is if
that's yeah if you're okay if there's
somebody who's okay to reveal that
two then they can do the pre-processing
but for example you can
you can secretary
exactly yeah exactly you can yeah
exactly so you
you know i'm more of an mpc person
actually than a private information
retrieval person so
you can imagine doing this setup via
some protocol where as long as you
assume that that they're not colluding
with each other
then you're sort of emulating this
trusted third party it's the same
setting
right model of interaction so in orange
you also keep a secret as a client yes
yes yes yeah so it kind of puts it yeah
this is
suggestively getting closer to oren
you you modify the database every time
you make the product yes
yes exactly
the point i guess is that the
pre-processing involves secrets that the
server should not know so whoever holds
on to these secrets would be able to
uh identify what's being queried later
on for example
there's no really
they aren't like inherit the secrets but
during the process
like the kitchen algorithm
uh yeah yeah well
like in a crs model
you'd have to also universally sample a
way of
yeah it's a big complication
yeah exactly if you're okay with
obfuscation then these are
one-time trust as opposed to every day
yes yes that's so that's a
in the good case does do the client have
the clients have the secret key or
nobody has the same nobody has the
secret key exactly so this in this case
the clients need the secret key to query
in this case
you kind of want to destroy the secret
key nobody needs the secret key and then
just given the public key
you can
okay
so um
so maybe let me kind of pause for a
second i've thrown out obfuscation here
this is a good time to mention
that even if i give you ideal
obfuscation forget about vbb and fine
tune i give you a magic black box
it's still not clear how to solve this
problem even this problem here um and
this is
you know i this is one of the explicit
challenge that i have later in my slides
um this is sort of
a surprising thing or they're not a
whole lot of natural goals
where where if you throw obfuscation at
it but it doesn't immediately solve so
this is maybe one thing to keep in mind
in this case um
yeah so for example you can think about
the the client does the pre-processing
and pushes this though the database over
for example
so maybe actually i have some explicit
slides that really give definitions of
these things so maybe for the fine
tuning um i the thing the point that i
want to
to kind of emphasize so here in order to
query i need the secret information that
was used for the pre-processing and here
there needs to be some secret
information but nobody needs to know it
in fact you don't want anybody to know
it so two people
do a multi-party thing
yes yes yes like we want one shot we do
a multi-party thing we generate it now
it's completely like normal
uh there's just something out in the sky
that everybody can use
to create this
so yes
yeah yeah for example
okay so so now this this is sort of the
spectrum here up here with
pre-processing
um and now what do we really know about
this uh well sort of the interesting and
part of what i want to try to focus on
today
is that in this setting
we have a candidate constructions this
is a two independent works back in 2017
um that give us very small communication
so polylog uh
here also polylog client storage
uh does have of course sort of
inherently the server storage needs to
to get bigger it needs to be so maybe it
doesn't need to be this big but it does
need to get bigger
so this is all fantastic
and the downside is that it's based on a
new assumption uh so downside in the
sense it's not a standard cryptographic
assumption but maybe also
this will lead to some interesting
additional questions
yes
so that fits into this box sort of right
uh in the sense you have per client
pre-processing as well yes
the amount of storage in the client is
much larger
the server is much smaller it really is
yes yes
but also yeah yeah so okay good so the
the down so the positives of this
um exactly the client storage is very
small
um and also
well you said something else server
storage is large so the server storage
is large the client storage is very
small the communication is smaller
communications
yeah yeah polylog versus square root
exactly
um but they can base on on standard
assumptions and we have this new
assumption so yeah there's definitely
like pros and cons i think the bigger
conceptual difference was that
that one is targeted to one client but
like the one in the next stock
service is good that's not true
that's not true
the server just leaves the database
yeah the client stores the i think the
server does just store the database this
is the pre-processing that we do that i
do as a server and time right that with
you and i can only use that sort of you
know um so if i want to do it with no i
have to do it again
sure but each client gets again
yeah i guess the ques it's like the same
thing the question is who stores this
information either it's stored on the
client side of the server side
great never mind
you'll we'll figure this out in the next
talk i guess
okay good so so this is sort of the
state of affairs and yeah so kind of
even even all of these things building
from even ideal obfuscation is very
interesting
yes this falls under the
a couple slides ago
here we know that the server storage
this is like the additional on top of n
so if you have s additional hint bits
if that's zero for example then the time
has to be
time is the server computation time
i'm not sure
yes
this
actually i'm not sure that's a good
point
this i'm not sure i'll have to check
i think it is because i think that this
the so okay this was in the original bim
paper and this was improved with the log
n and this um this is cristiano lanielle
and i think that so this in their paper
i think they're looking at a case with
their secrets but i need to check that
um pre-processing time so in all these
cases it's polynomial like the specific
polynomial uh we haven't looked so
closely yet
leave that as an efficiency open
question
for the lower bound i don't think it
matters no it's like
yes yes
s plus plus plus
if you say new assumption
this is good user is a co-author so i
think it's pretty much it's been out
there five years it's an old assumption
now yeah that's pretty old it's pretty
old
um like how confident am i in the
assumption we'll get to that later i
would certainly not bet my life on it
but so far it's it's held so we'll see
okay um yeah so first of all i this this
is great all the interaction as we said
before simon's is really good for this
um because of that i might need to skip
over some later parts but i'm totally
cool with that
okay so this talk um first of all kind
of showing you the lay of the land
um i mostly just want to tell you a
couple odds and ends interesting things
about these three intermediate notions
um so this is based on who's doing the
pre-processing mostly focusing on the
weakest version of the secret key d e
pure uh and i want to make sure that i
have time at the end so to tell a lot of
open questions and challenges
okay
so first of all this is like the
strongest version
and when we started on this this uh
this problem i think about 50 50 percent
of the time we were either trying to
build a construction or actually show
that this is impossible
um
but it turns out
it's going to be challenging to show
impossibility and the reason is because
you can do one of these tricky sort of
things if
if some sort of dream data structure
existed
maybe we don't expect this to exist but
we don't know how to prove it does not
exist yet then you would get
a construction
and just very briefly so what is this
dream data structure okay suppose i have
some way of converting a circuit size
maybe k to 100 to some
polynomial blow up data structure
such that evaluating the circuit one of
the input can be done by looking at some
kind of small number of positions in the
data structure
let's see k to the 10 lookups
okay so suppose that such a thing
existed
now take your favorite two message
standard no pre-processing private
information retrieval scheme
okay so this
whatever the server is doing here
um this is something that takes a lot of
time right this is the time to end in
the existing constructions but now view
this as a circuit that has the databases
inside of it
now convert that circuit using your
dream data structure
and given
given an input which is like a query
from the the client you can evaluate
what would the circuit say by looking at
a small number of positions in this data
structure okay this exactly gives you up
here with pre-processing
um so this this is something we kind of
observed in 2017 paper it's a related
highly to something that's in the
original window at all
uh and as i said what the means is that
ruling out this this primitive
uh is going to require new data
structure lower bounds which
whenever i hear that they sort of start
walking in the other direction
[Music]
what was the question you mean for what
you're looking at here but that's
automatically guaranteed because i'm
starting with the input to the circuit
i i already know that you it's only
evaluating on a query i'm starting with
a secure
two uh two message protocol
so i guess
so inherently so where i'm looking at
here depends only on the query that the
client was sending not on i but the
query that he was sending in the
original protocol
so the only thing the only thing that's
going on security follows exactly in the
same way the only thing that's being
improved is efficiency here you had to
do some
computation size n
or more circuit now here i'm achieving
that by this crazy data structure
okay
okay so this is actually all i'm going
to say about the standard keyword
preprocessing where the servers doing
the pre-processing
kind of take one step back
and look at this public key doubly
efficient peer just to remind you so the
goal is that suppose that there's some
trusted setup face either trusted party
or or a few of us running a one-time
protocol
takes x and encodes it into some capital
x and also posts some public key
associated with that okay and maybe
there were secrets in this generation
they get destroyed
nobody needs the secrets
okay now different clients come along
each of them want some
index of the original database
uh and given just the public key they'll
be able to access a small number of
positions in this encoded database
okay
i don't want so there's no shared
secrets between the clients note that
that's the case uh and of course that
the accesses that are observed are
hiding though the indices that are
actually wanted
okay um
maybe
this is like a formal definition of the
are you interested in formal
can you tell the same location has been
accessed twice in a row no you should
not be able to tell
yeah and then that's a it's a good point
so kind of you inherently need some kind
of randomness in this okay so i think
actually i will go through even though
maybe it's a little bit dry here um so
somewhat more formally what's kind of
the syntax so say if some
you kind of explicitly split this into
two parts some kind of generation and
encoding procedure
can if you want to think of these as the
same same uh chunk
okay so this part is what's done by the
trusted party
and now this everything that's blue is
going to be stuff that's thrown away you
don't you don't need it
aside from the b and b w that one's
clearly very important
okay um and the green stuff is public so
this in particular
the public key and and this is public in
the sense that it's we don't know it
right but it's not hidden it's not
something we're trying to hide
okay so now i'm a client i see the
public key
i know my this is the
per party kind of secret information the
per query there's i is the thing i want
there's some randomness i'm choosing to
generate the query
this indicates a
subset of positions into this encoded
database
um and i effectively tell the server i
want these symbols
i get those data values back
and as a function of that and also note
that kind of the secrets that were
that i i generated as part of the query
generation i can decode the the desired
value the i value of the original
database
the correctness is as you'd expect
non-triviality i want it to be that that
the number of query like number of
positions i'm looking at is small
and the security so what is the server
see note that the server does not i mean
this is exactly kind of the point that
the server doesn't see the the secret
key
so he can't do the
pre-processing but somehow the
pre-processing goes down
the server uh even say knows the public
key the original database the encoded x
uh and it sees the positions here that
were queried and it should not know what
was the desired index
okay
good
so this is the public key version
on the question that was just before so
if i reveal whether our queries are
repeated does it get suspension easier
so
um
[Music]
it seems like maybe maybe randomly
permute yeah this is i think yeah i
think you could basically just do it's
like oh ram but if you never have repeat
queries then i think you can just do a
one-shot permutation at least in the
secret key setting it should be but
you're so you're allowing updates on the
server
there's no updates there's no updates so
we're not like that basically this
trivial solution does not work for us
okay
okay so now kind of like grade out the
things from the previous slide and the
secret key version is going to be
similar but not the same
so in this case um
so this is now going to be all kind of
done by a client
so the client's generating the secret
key and doing this encoding
okay now the the encoded database is is
going off to the to the server side
and the queries in order to query now in
the secret key version you need to know
the secret key information
so this is you know less desirable but
this is something we can get more bold
on okay and similarly to decode you need
the secret key information
okay this is all done on the client
um but the kind of these properties down
here are pretty analogous actually
okay so so this yeah
you could think about how would you like
where would this be useful right so say
like the client does one's one time
pre-processing and then uploads to this
to the cloud to the server
or yeah or you can have like outsource
the process to somebody you trust and
then you just need the secret key for
example
okay
okay
okay just uh so so these are kind of the
two notions um just a quick mention
so suppose i told you that there's this
conversion from the secret key to the
public key version if i give you
obfuscation
this is actually maybe not such a
surprise so take like these secret
uh secret algorithms suppose i start
with this secret key version that
require the secret key okay
now stick those in an obfuscated box
um and effectively what i'm going to do
is is this obfuscated program is going
to be posted as the public key
so the you know it takes as input what
were the other the other inputs that you
needed for example for the query or for
the decoding
uh and it hides the secret key inside of
it but allows the the rest of it and
okay so it's not immediate i mean you
have to do a little bit of work you have
to authenticate to make sure that the
box is not being used in ways it's not
supposed to
so you you want to keep the randomness
as an explicit input to this or let the
thing generate randomness i do i do oh
it actually doesn't really matter
um but it needs to then output the
randomness like you n it needs to be
that you need to know the randomness
that was used for the queer in order to
decode
but i don't really yeah i don't really
care we wanted to keep this is easier if
this is a deterministic program but
okay um yeah first
some cryptographers in the group um i we
don't know how to do this with the
weaker notion of obfuscation i mean we
didn't try like super hard um
but uh
but interestingly enough there might be
challenges in that so there was this
work back in 2015 of um
alvin segev that showed some kind of
black box separation actually from if i
give you i o and one-way functions it's
not clear that that actually gives you
private information retrieval so
it doesn't really fully apply but maybe
this is something to be aware of
this doesn't have anything to say
anything about like doubly efficient or
anything this is just yes yes just just
it's interesting so the
the secret key version and i'm going to
i'm going to push this to the side
there's things that are
a little non-obvious but this is not
something i want to take my minutes on
okay uh things i do want to take a
little bit more time on
so so even on focusing just on this
weakest version the secret key version
um and what do we know about it as an
object so obviously it's hard we don't
really know how to build it
from even strong tools
and
what can we prove it implies was a
little bit comparatively a little
pathetic uh it does imply one-way
function
uh basically you can so that this is
kind of the details of why is that the
case
um and actually i don't even want to get
into it i can go into details of people
interesting
not ot or publicly encryption uh
we don't know
we don't know yeah
um
what
we use
yes yes
yeah yeah yeah i'll mention that a
little bit
that's a good point
okay uh something that's that's maybe a
little bit more interesting
is that this this object
actually implies
a locally decodable code
okay so first of all a locally decodable
cloud this is you know an object in
encoding theory which allows you to take
some
message okay for example the database x
and encode it in some way
that you can recover
recover symbols of x
even so just by looking at a small
number of positions and even if there's
errors
in in this code word
um so
okay so obviously so our notion doesn't
have any sort of
error guarantees everybody's assuming
the server is giving the right values
and so forth
um but it does imply such a notion not a
huge surprise because we do know that
that private information retrieval
implies these things
again so i'm not getting into it uh this
i don't i actually don't even know that
this implies private information
retrieval we've kind of backed off so
much with a secret key version
so this is not trivial but it's a
similar approach
um via some kind of smoothness so
roughly speaking in order to um in order
to have security it means that the
positions you're looking at need to be
at least computationally independent of
of the index that i want to query which
means you have to kind of spread them
around
which gives you some kind of local
decoding property
okay so so this is particularly
interesting to me for one reason
which means that in some sense this is
this kind of guides where do we need to
go in order to construct such a thing
okay
so that if i want to build the secret
key depr i kind of need to start with
maybe a locally decodable code and build
from that otherwise what we're going to
be doing is a new way of designing
locally decodable codes which actually
is also interesting but uh there's been
a lot of work already in local decodable
codes we might as well leverage that
so maybe
i might be wrong but uh isn't the
implication to locally decorable codes
from multi-server information
theoretically that implies it easily
implies locally i guess not easily oh i
seriously
but single server pir
it may not have a locally decodable
query yeah so you're right this you're
right this this is multi-server
um what we're doing but it's a similar
sort of
it's a similar approach it's not it
doesn't fall directly yeah but it's a
similar argument
okay and finally so going back to uh to
ask but some the question of
what about implying something like
public encryption or oblivious transfer
um and the answer is we don't know
and not only do we not know that this
object
and whether it implies public encryption
but as you've all said even the concrete
assumption that we're going to have a
candidate construction of this from we
don't know if that implies publicly
encryption
um but in some sense
for us in a particular setting we
actually take this as good news
um because you'll see in a second the
candidate like the assumption that's
underlying this
if it did imply public encryption that'd
be a bit suspicious
and i'll talk about that when we get to
it
okay
so we'll get to it very very soon
so the next kind of chunk i have a
few slides about i want to tell you
about what is this candidate
construction look like of the secret key
doubly efficient pair
and i'm going to be focusing on sort of
the simplest version there's a few
different variations and so forth and
this was in in two
concurrent papers in 2017.
okay i said that this is based on a new
assumption let me first introduce you to
what this assumption looks like
okay it's some form of permuted
low-degree curves conjecture
um for everything i'm just going to draw
in two dimensions this is much much
easier
but you can consider this in a
multi-dimensional version and in fact in
order to get the parameters i quoted you
need higher than two dimensions
okay so it's going to be an
indistinguishability type definition
on one side
we're going to start with low degree
parametric curves okay low degree in the
sense of say that this is
uh so this is to say that this is like
capital n by capital n okay
what do i mean by these load low degree
parametric curves i mean
um
evaluation points where the first
coordinate is dictated by some low
degree polynomial on a parameter the
second coordinate is dictated by some
other low degree polynomial in the same
parameter okay so these can maybe like
cross around or whatever but it's it's
not it's relatively low degree
okay we'll have lots of them
distribution 2 is going to be the same
thing except instead of having a low
degree polynomial in each position i
just have a truly random function in
each position
okay so pause for a second
um clearly these are not
indistinguishable
you can distinguish them right
uh or at least however however i've i've
written them this is sort of p one of t
comma p two of t yes yes exactly and so
i've drawn it as a curve just kind of
for viewing purposes but you're right
it's actually just a collection of
points
okay but but even as the collection of
points these as they are right now are
these are very distinguishable
okay now
no there's an important word i have not
covered yet the permuted part
um for simplicity say the entire curve
you you you don't need in
just like a subset of points actually
you can even i'll show the construction
and the next slide you just need like a
random collection of enough points on
this curve
neither of them really are curves
they're just points but these points
happen they would interpolate to
something smooth and these are just like
totally random
what it is is each coordinate just is
either a low degree polynomial or each
coordinate to stay truly truly random
and yeah so by the way so as the
dimension goes higher there's even more
structure so it becomes a stronger
assumption um but it gives us better
parameters it's also a trade-off there
particularly right now it's it's
broken just by looking at one point yes
yes yes yes yeah very so i'm like
on the verge of actually describing this
and indeed yes so there's one very
important part of this
um which is that we're not going to give
you access to these these plots of
points but instead
once and for all i'm going to sample a
random secret permutation
on the the n squared so this is a full
shuffle of the whole
n squared points
and in each instance you do not actually
get to see the curve as it is but you
see the curve with pi applied
so each of these is permuted
you get as many samples as you want
keep pressing a button kind of getting
either from here say or from here
um and the version that you get the
question is once i apply this
are these indistinguishable and and not
first first of all if i just give you
say one sample or a small number of
samples
this is information theoretically the
same distribution oh i see so you pick
the pie once and for all and you keep
doing it for many many yes yes many the
same pie every single time and then this
is where so eventually you kind of use
up the entropy of the permutation you
have to be computational yes yes exactly
so at some point this becomes where it
has it's a computational
question can you have the computational
algorithms to distinguish these things
okay so this this uh this is sort of the
underlying assumption
okay
now uh so now let me describe to you
what is the the construction suppose
that this holds
a okay
so as you might expect this generation
procedure is going to sample a random
permutation
okay and because so you can think of
this this stands for pseudorandom
permutation i basically just need i want
some sort of uh compressed
representation of something that's
random enough okay
so otherwise i mean the construction
correctness and everything holds for a
truly random permutation but the storage
would be very high
okay so this is just compressing the
representation there
okay
okay now for the encoding
start with the database x
first thing we're going to do is encode
x using a read molar code this is a
locally decodable code
okay roughly what does it mean so take
the symbols here say we're over some
finite field
okay stick them in the corner and do a
low degree extension of this thing
very proud of parts of this slide
so so this is kind of this is encoding
as this degree roughly square root and
surface
okay and the final step of course so i
have this and i'm going to the thing
that i actually this is the final
encoded database that i give to the
server just to hold on to
is going to be this but permuted
with pi which is uh
shuffling all the coordinates of this
thing
okay
so suppose now i want to make a query
so the secret key i know what pi is and
i'm interested in index i which is some
index of the original
database
okay so and for those who have you know
taken the coding theory class
um how you would normally decode a read
molar code
is you throw a random line here say here
you'd query all the points
this would so that would correspond over
to here this would allow you to
interpolate the curve and extrapolate
what's here
okay
in our case i'm going to do essentially
the same thing but instead of a line
i'm going to do something that's higher
degree this is going to be for the part
of the secrecy
that i'm going to need
okay
so here this is going to be a random let
degree lambda here represents the
security parameter curve through this
point
okay
you could think of lambda as something
like poly logarithmic in the the
database size
okay so so this this is what it's going
to be note that this point corresponds
here
and that means
this one i'm less proud of but you can
still kind of see here
so so this curve this is like the floor
um and what i want to do is i want to
query enough points on here to
to again to interpolate this now higher
degree curve
so before if this was aligned the degree
of the
the the one dimensional kind of thing
curve that i'm cutting would be square
root and
now because my my floor curve is a
lambda
now i need roughly lambda square root n
plus one points in order to interpolate
this thing
okay
okay so so choose basically there's this
curve i'll choose enough a random
collection of enough points
uh to to interplay
uh with with this point removed
okay
good okay good so these these are kind
of the points i'm querying and now using
read more decoding which is truly just
now interpolating sort of like taking
what is this thing flattening it out and
doing a polynomial interpolation i can
recover what was
the value stored in this position which
corresponds exactly to the
ice entry here
yeah actually so i shouldn't have put
these dots here you you you can it's
best if you do it where you don't query
anything in the the message position it
keeps a bit safer
okay so now what's going on
so this this kind of explains and feel
free to tell me if you have questions
this sort of explains hopefully
correctness how am i doing the recovery
and now what about security so what the
server sees
is that exactly
points on some degree
lambda curve
okay over sampling this is i'm getting
something like square root and lambda
points onto the green line the curve
but these points are permuted
okay so this exactly kind of falls back
a module of some small details to the
assumption from the previous slide
so
this is a general template to go from
any locally i suppose smooth to locally
decodable code uh to to to yes yes yes
yes for sure and the corresponding under
the underlying corresponding assumption
is just that whatever the distribution
is there if you permute it yeah
yes
the square root of n you can make that
smaller by choosing like more variance
the yeah exactly so so this is like the
two variant and what i'm saying
dimension i think at some point so this
is like a two variant read mark if you
crank up the number of variables then
the the degree drops down
certainly
wrong
should we like them
um so the information that's being
learned is
uh can sort of massage it right the
information that's being learned is
exactly
like you're
permuted
yeah that's right that's right yeah so
yeah yeah abstractly thinking yeah
yeah that's a good point i was sort of
not explicitly mentioning this yeah the
view it's like enough to consider that
the guy just sees the positions
of them because for example the data
contents themselves can just be
encrypted okay that's a good point
okay
okay um so given time let me just kind
of
briefly say a few things because i want
to to shift gears soon
um
so what do we know so far about this
candidate and we'll see the the
underlying assumption
um so it's proved in in this other work
this is kennedy holmgren and richelson
that if some sort of bounded query
security does hold proof-of-way and
maybe not a huge
surprise um standard decoding attacks so
what do i mean i mean trying to decode
read molar codes
heavily
and heavily relies on needing to know
kind of what do the different positions
of this code word mean
um
i maybe don't want to go so deep into
these things just a quick mention uh so
there are variants of the mcleese crypto
system this without saying much about it
it says like some sort of permuted uh
code
that that goes out there but but one
important difference so
mclee's crypto system with reid
settlement is broken and this is a good
thing to know
uh an important distinction between that
case and our case uh so loosely speaking
that they have to kind of publish um
like they put they they they publish
like the pub the public key information
there is kind of some version of the
generator matrix which is something that
we don't have to reveal or rather we're
kind of putting obfuscation on on top of
that in order to do something with the
public key
um so it seems like the attacks in that
case don't apply for us
okay this they don't want to mention but
there's a like a totally generic
learning approach that
doesn't necessarily apply here
okay i should say however that there are
if you kind of back off or change some
things about the assumption we do know
that versions of this can be broken
so for example if i don't have a
permutation but i just try to do the
read more
with noise
um decoding attacks will apply they're
actually quite good in these sorts of
regimes um and and kind of the amount of
noise that you would need to add in
order to drown out the signal there
would be too much to be to be
interesting
also by the way if you just permit the x
coordinate or the y coordinate
um some of these may be like good
exercises for you to go that you can
break it
if you have a public linear encoding
so for example if you had some sort of
linear ldc locally decodable code
without a permutation this you can break
and also the decoding
is linear in public so for example
this goes back to another question if i
always use exactly the same
interpolation points then this is
something a bit dangerous
[Music]
and so even more recently this is these
are two notes that were posted on on
eprint this last year
um
so in in one of the 2017 papers we put
forth
like a weaker version of the assumption
a toy challenge
the big distinction
is instead of having parametric curves
you effectively have the special case
where the first coordinate is always
just the parameter so this is like now a
function for example here and this is a
random function
and it really uses the fact
in particular that i know that there
exists like these columns that will
always have exactly one dot in it and
that kind of helps separate things
and then you can put linearization on
top of it so this this is together with
uh
justin lucio fermi who's here and more
vice and another group did it
independently
[Music]
um and also in these papers so this was
like an original toy version but there's
new toy versions
and and this basically this attack does
not apply to the actual candidates that
were in the original
papers okay so in my field remaining
minutes let me now push push the burden
onto you guys uh so here are some
interesting open questions
first of all first challenge break the
assumption
um there's a lot of people in this room
who i think would do you know
a very good job of that or at least
taking a look at it
so again kind of what is
the flavor of the assumption
um it's like these parametric curves
where you get collections of
the permuted
values
um and even even a little bit more
explicitly so
and i didn't didn't kind of write it on
the slides but exactly this issue say
that each time you get a random
selection of the points so the the
choice of the parameter is different
okay
sure this is if you're a pessimist if
you're an optimist supports the
assumption okay
so ideally
we'd love to have some sort of relation
reducing showing security based on some
kind of more standard assumption
um that might be challenging but that
would be really interesting
another kind of approach to try to do is
to rule out different classes of attacks
so for example
in the work does the work with justin
and mor from 2019 we at least address
this class of statistical query attacks
and could rule them out
of course we could unfortunately also
rule them out for the
for the toy version which is broken but
this is still something that can be said
okay and uh so this this is like a very
specific with these low degree curves
but you can actually consider this as a
broader class of assumptions which i
think is actually quite interesting
um so so here the question is suppose i
have two
you know other choices of distributions
say i have pictures of cats and pictures
of dogs okay
is it the case
that so certainly now we have amazing
technology for distinguishing you know
throw it into some neural network tells
you this is a dog this is a cat
now suppose i i have a once and for all
choose a permutation like shuffling the
pixels
is it do these things break down
having weight of cats and dogs is the
same right so yeah suppose that you take
from distributions yeah i tried to match
it up so this is like kind of more green
this is more green
suppose that you have the basic
statistics or are the same across them
um
so so for example like convolutional
neural networks which are really good
with images do use proximity of things i
am not a machine learning expert um
those who are more into it i'd be really
interested in talking and seeing
does this kill
or or is it sort of agnostic to the
actual choice the coordinates of
positions of these pixels or not
okay so kind of a more theoretical side
so this was
this notion was put forth in the
original 2017 paper and in the 2019
paper um justin moore we looked a little
bit more in detail about this class of
problems
so but there's still you know we made
some progress but there's still a lot of
questions that we don't know so for
example what properties are necessary or
sufficient for this this kind of
transformation of easy to hard
i'd love to be able to prove something
like this
if the original pair of distributions
have some property
then when you permute them
now they're indistinguishable
something like this would be really
interesting
another class of things that we looked
at
suppose can you show that based on
assumption why something that you know
we believe is is true then that there
are these pairs that somehow the the
permutation can give hardness
so like pairs of distributions that on
their own are distinguishable but now
based on this assumption why when i put
the permutation on top of them they're
provably indistinguishable we have a
couple examples in the paper by the way
lpn itself can essentially be
viewed
as a form of this directly
you're saying you can come up with
examples
of these this sort of permuted puzzles
using yes
you know we're sort of choosing what are
the pairs of the districts
okay so this is kind of one thing the
looking at the underlying type of
assumptions
the other is looking straight to the
goals these these objects these versions
appear with pre-processing
okay and and um there's also a ton of
questions here as i said uh building
even even the weakest version of this
the secret key d e pure from any kind of
standard assumptions um so for example
we were kind of excited for a while
maybe we can turn this permutation plus
noise somehow tied to to like a learning
parody with noise saying maybe that that
could imply hardness somehow we weren't
able to do that but i think that's still
really interesting direction
and quite honestly our bar is pretty low
here
so anything anything as i said even take
obfuscation okay can you build this i'd
be really interested to hear
um
okay so so this obviously this is maybe
one of the
the downsides depending on how you feel
about this new type of assumption
um but but there are interesting things
even with this new assumption if you
believe it or you're kind of
sufficiently happy with it and it does
give a lot of good properties and this
might be worth pursuing even further can
you get like good concrete efficiency
um trying to better understand the
relation between these different notions
also notions like the you know batch
pier that we'll be hearing about soon
and even before so for example in the
other kinds of settings there are
questions looking at things like
incremental database updates can you how
can that kind of incorporate are there
upper bounds lower bounds there we don't
know
okay so uh to summarize and conclude
so so first of all remember the very
beginning kind of the main message of
this talk
we're looking at single server private
information retrieval and trying to
bypass this inherent
linear server and computation time and
there's a couple different ways of doing
that so in the next talk you know stay
tuned you'll see a different version and
what i've been talking about is a
version where you're encoding the
database
okay so we talked about these three
different notions a little bit about
relations
uh between them and also other objects
um and in focusing a lot on this
candidate construction
okay so i've already talked about the
open directions i'll leave these up here
and with this i will conclude
questions
[Music]
it depends a little bit on the trade-off
space that you that you want
and so with read more like as you
okay as you increase the number of
variables or like the dimension of this
thing the number of positions that you
have to create drops down but the size
of the encoding gets bigger so there's a
couple different creative points but the
short version is that we haven't been
like trying to optimize things
sure can i just think about that
and then you can gather to eat the same
complexity um
yeah so rather except that the
assumption also ties if you're saying
it's like a totally different type of
structure locally the quotable code then
you're right that
this framework exactly gives you a
construction
that's exactly the overhead the thing
that also changes with it is what is the
computational assumption where does this
action it's that basically permuted
kind of queries from this query set
and look
don't reveal what is the thing that
you're trying to access
um
i don't want to
actually it's a good question so what
are these like these multiplicity codes
that have
great one
yeah yeah it's definitely definitely
trade-offs and sort of though
but um yeah
we're trying to make it i think it would
give
asymptotically pretty good numbers
concrete
i think we are behind so we'll get more
questions it all right
again